donald trump versus joe biden that's the
choice facing the american people
lots of americans will be voting by mail
rather than in person
to stay socially distanced and safe but
many voters and
experts worry that the u.s isn't ready
and equipped to count all of those
mail-in ballots in time to announce a
winner immediately
and the president has been extremely
vocal about his opposition
to mail-in voting and you don't have to
know a lot about elections you don't
have to know a lot about politics
this is going to be the scam of all time
without the clear winner when the polls
close
the very legitimacy of the election
could be questioned
it's possible to imagine violent clashes
you know on the order
of something we haven't seen in this
country in several decades
but there's no evidence of widespread
fraud
in fact the president himself votes by
mail
so i'm signing today an absentee ballot
but many trump supporters have heard his
rhetoric and are highly skeptical
i'm very concerned because i think
there's too much room for fraud
everybody wants to take him down and
that would be a good way to do it
normally the winner of the election
becomes clear in the early hours of the
morning
shortly after the polls close and
confirm that donald trump
will be the 45th president
of the united states but counting and
verifying a large number of mail-in
ballots
means a fast turnaround result is
unlikely
you're not going to know this possibly
if you really did it right
for months or for years it is certainly
uh not unlikely that the count of
mainland ballots
could take days or even weeks you really
have to
physically open the envelopes there's
sort of tests that you have to do
to make sure that the signature on the
envelope for example
agrees with a signature on record
polling shows
that democrats are more likely to vote
by mail than republicans who are more
likely to vote
in person this could mean that early
results show that trump has done better
but as mail in ballots are accounted for
there could be a swing to biden
then it is possible you know that trump
could be pretty successful in muddying
the waters
claiming that the mail and ballots need
to be discredited
there's no doubt that when you're
dealing with these millions of mail-in
ballots there
are going to be instances of um human
error battles are going to be mistakenly
discarded they're going to be
put in the wrong spot and unfortunately
that simply becomes grist
for trump's conspiracy theories
we could see drama unfold in places like
pennsylvania
michigan and wisconsin trump won those
swing states by a
razor thin margin in 2016 and their
rules on processing absentee ballots
means that counting could take a while
if the mail-in votes start to indicate a
win for biden
then republicans already critical of the
process
could file lawsuits to delay counting
and
even discount those votes in the 2000
presidential election
a recount in the crucial state of
florida put the result of the election
on hold
for more than a month the supreme court
eventually intervened
and al gore conceded making george w
bush the 43rd president of the united
states
while i strongly disagree with the
court's decision
i accept it after election day on the
3rd of november
states have until the 8th of december to
count the votes and determine which
candidate has won the state
under a system known as the electoral
college
if counting is still going on at that
point then congress
might have to step in but the house and
senate might not agree
if congress can't decide the result of
the election then democrats could argue
that the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi become acting president
republicans are unlikely to accept that
and could try to inaugurate donald trump
to a second term it could then be up to
the supreme court
to decide the result of the election but
if i see
tens of thousands of ballots being
manipulated i can't go along with that
and i'll tell you what from a common
sense does that mean you're telling
other people
it means you have a fraudulent election
he has no idea what he's talking about
here's the deal
the fact is i will accept it and he will
too you know why
because once the winner is declared
after all the all the ballots are
counted
all the votes are counted that'll be the
end of it i don't imagine that trump is
going to barricade himself in the white
house
and that he's going to need to be uh
frog marched out of the white house
by members of the military but what i do
imagine
is that no matter what happens that
he'll never concede
i think he will continue to say that uh
even if i've lost decisively he was all
a hoax it's all a ripped election
the 2020 election could trigger a
constitutional crisis
and fracture an already divided nation
even further
an uncertain result could spur protests
and violence
the battle for the white house could
play out in the congress the courts and
the street
as both sides say democracy is under
siege